uh we'll listen man
season two when is that dropping do we
know uh probably like the summer
December the summer the summer okay
coming soon would you do any spin-off
shows obviously this is kind of like a
spin-off on Zeus because she was on the
other show
and it's something like Wu-Tang
everybody do some blue Girls Club [__]
like some no he's not unless I'm
incorporating so blue Girls Club is
coming against
so you're not allowed to no that's what
I'm breaking up with
him I know when people want to know
you're always trying not to include me
and [__]
you say that now and that's not the case
you said that before because you did it
before
that's her manager do you think I should
have her on Blue Girls Club our only
fans
season four why is she doing the whole
Zeus and the crazy in love
are you still doing the only fan [__] no
I just kind of like shut up decided like
to go to the next Zeus is bigger than
that right
yeah yeah for sure the only fans yeah
did you say he's single
oh
would you guys say that you guys are on
and off a lot
he's whatever you want to do whatever
I'm on all the time she's off she's old
enough why are you lying
why are you lying um
well listen I think you guys I've always
you know I always tell people blue I
think you're a smart guy
Krishan I think that you have to uh
understand that you have like a level of
stardom right now that is very rare and
I think that y'all gotta you know clean
this [__] up a little
shut the [__] up
I'm just like I don't want nobody going
to jail I don't want you know I haven't
been a joke since the last time I've
been in jail
well when was that I think Valentine's
Day the last Valentine's Day so it's
been over a year yeah it's been a minute
oh that easy part but like I was
probably like six seven eight months ago
right well let's try this yeah you was
in Phoenix I remember seeing it let's
try to stay out of jail we got a kid on
the way I know
do you think motherhood is going to
change you Christian
you are like you hope so I'm fine I'm
fine
you need to change
is it safe to say everyone needs to
change everyone should be self-improving
at all times in the world right if you
ain't get it
is changing
I mean I didn't say that I just said do
you think I mean fatherhood motherhood
changes people so yeah
I mean uh started planning for the
future a little bit more
than I used to
well look I just want y'all to like
be safe be healthy
a little less toxic you guys have a lot
of dope [__] going on
Chris Sean if you I think if you took
the music [__] real serious it'd be
crazy for you you know what I mean I
think you would go up I think you need
to start working with some writers some
dope producers
and all
the [__]
the TV [__] is cool but it's got an
expiration date you know what I mean the
music [__] the you just gotta just sit
back and watch my boy I mean we always
cross Brando like on our show like right
we um we like executive producers so we
got more like say so as far as the music
in the background right